ist das größte müllproblem der
menschheit gelöst plastikmüll kaum
abbaubar verseuchte unsere umwelt tötet
ihre und landet schließlich wieder mit
gefährlichen schadstoffen angereichert
beim menschen einfach nur eine solche
dieses zeug jetzt scheint sich aber eine
lösung anzubahnen und mal wieder hat
kommissar zufall seine hände im spiel
und die mottenlarven galeria melo nella
was das besondere an dieser lage ist um
wie sie das plastik müll problem lösen
kann jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen frederik bertolini
ist nicht nur biologin an der
universität santander in spanien sondern
auch hobby imkerin und das hat ihr
wahrscheinlich eine bahnbrechende
entdeckung ermöglicht polyethylen kurz
ist ein sehr widerstandsfähiger
kunststoff wodurch er zum beispiel
perfekt für getränkeflaschen geeignet
ist er ist aus unserem alltag nicht mehr
wegzudenken und macht und 40 prozent des
hergestellten kunststoff aus aber was in
so widerstandsfähig macht ist auch sein
größtes problem er ist nämlich sehr
schwer abbaubar und sammelt sich an
allen ecken und enden wie zb in ozean
nach jüngsten studien hat sich die
müllmenge seit 2004 zum teil
verzwanzigfacht das gilt für die arktis
dort landet der müll zum teil durch die
meeresströmung und zum teil wird er auch
in eis eingeschlossen und so
transportiert durch die schmelze im
frühling landet der plastikmüll dann
selbst an entlegensten orten über die
jahrzehnte wird der run zermahlen und
landet angereichert mit schadstoffen
durch den fisch stehen wir essen dann
wieder bei uns mal zeit
aber das könnte bald ein ende haben denn
frederica bertolini hat bei der
mottenlarven galeria melo nella
erstaunliches festgestellt diese lage
ist nämlich in der lage zu zersetzen in
kürzester zeit frisst sich durch
plastiktüten und schon der kontakt mit
ihnen zersetzt sie das bietet für das
forscherteam einen spannenden ansatz
denn offensichtlich verfügt die läufe
über ein enzym das schon von sich aus pe
in seine bestandteile zerlegt suchen die
forscher und forscherinnen nach diesem
enzym könnte es in großem maßstab
produziert werden wäre ein weg zum abbau
von pe gefunden erika berger chini steht
übrigens auf die besondere fähigkeit der
läufer durch einen zufall die
mottenlarven ist nämlich
in bienenstöcken also sie ihr hobby ein
parasit und frisst das wachs was einen
ganz ähnlichen aufbau wie polyethylen
hat die hobby imkerin hatte einen
bienenstock von den larven befreit und
hatte sie in eine plastiktüte gesteckt
diese erfassen sie in kürzester zeit
eine entdeckung wahr gemacht und die
larven sind dabei sogar doppelt so
schnell wie die im letzten jahr
entdeckten plastik fressen bakterien
über die wir ja hier berichtet hat
natürlich halten wir euch über dieses
thema auch auf dem laufenden damit er
nichts verpasst wird mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke wenn ihr blick so ein bisher noch
nicht abonniert habt dann habt ihr das
hier verpasst die besten videos von
pixum science fiction und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran